[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNA FREBEL: It's a very
fundamental question
for humanity to ask,
where do we come from?
And we are, in some
sense, A) trying
to study that, and B) trying
to educate everyone about that.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're talking star stuff.
In this episode,
we're going to be
exploring stellar archaeology
and the origins of, well,
everything.
ANNA FREBEL: It all comes from
the cosmos, from the stars,
and from the
supernova explosions.
SARAH HANSEN: Our guest
today is associate professor
of Physics, Anna Frebel.
In a series of
short videos created
to go with her book Searching
for the Oldest Stars,
she reveals the
secrets of stardust
and explains the cosmic
origins of the elements.
ANNA FREBEL: Hello.
My name is Anna Frebel.
I'm a physics professor at MIT,
but I'm actually an astronomer.
So I sit in the
Astrophysics division,
and I search for the oldest
stars in the universe.
And it's really cool.
And I think we're going to
talk a lot more about that.
SARAH HANSEN: It is pretty cool.
And what's even cooler is that
by the end of this podcast,
you'll understand
what she does, even
if your prior experience
with astronomy,
like mine, starts and ends with
gazing at the stars and saying,
wait, is that the Big Dipper?
And that's exactly why we
wanted to have her on this show.
She's an expert
science communicator.
She conveys complex topics
in inspiring and clear ways.
As the title of
her book suggests,
much of Professor
Frebel's work is
rooted in learning more about
the origins of the elements
by studying the oldest
stars in the universe.
I was curious how old
we were talking about.
ANNA FREBEL: We
want to figure out
exactly how element
formation proceeds.
And you have to look at
different types of objects
in the cosmos to figure it
out because all the elements
are made there.
Now, if you take the
sun, for example,
the sun is about 4.6
billion years old.
And the universe is about
13.8 billion years old.
So the sun and its
content reflects
the state of the universe
4.5 or 4.6 billion years ago.
Now, that's pretty cool that we
get this kind of information.
But it actually is
much better for us
to look at stars
that are much older,
that are formed sooner
after the Big Bang.
And that's why we look
at the oldest stars.
By studying the
composition of these stars,
we can then figure out what
produced all these elements
that we're seeing in the stars.
SARAH HANSEN: This process
of looking to the oldest
stars for information about the
building blocks of the universe
is called "stellar archaeology."
And it helps us look into
the past, way into the past.
ANNA FREBEL: We are
archaeologists of sorts.
We are really good in
piecing together the past
because every distant object
whose light we're seeing
has traveled some time to us.
And we are now seeing it as
when, for example, a galaxy was
in its baby stage,
we're seeing that now.
So that lets us
explore the past.
Now, these stars that we are
exploring are in the Milky Way.
And that's really our
local cosmic neighborhood.
The light travel time
within our galaxy
is thousands of years,
perhaps, at least to the stars
that we're looking at.
So compared to the
age of the universe,
that's next to nothing.
So we are not looking for
stars that are very distant
and whose light has traveled
to us for literally a gazillion
years.
We are looking for
stars that are truly old
and still sitting there.
And again, by studying
their composition,
we can then learn what
the universe looked
like at the time
of their formation
soon after the Big Bang.
SARAH HANSEN: You might be
wondering how a scientist does
this sort of work, this
stellar archaeology, digging
into the farthest
reaches of the universe.
You'd have to use some of the
best telescopes in the world.
And it's definitely
not something
you could set up
in your backyard.
ANNA FREBEL: You have to fly
to South America to Chile
because most of the big
telescopes are located there.
Others are located in Hawaii.
And while this sounds
like a vacation,
it's really anything but.
[ANNA FREBEL LAUGHS]
So you usually fly
through Miami or Atlanta.
And then you have
to get to Santiago,
to Chile, the capital of Chile.
And then you have to fly another
hour from there to La Serena.
And then you get
picked up by a car,
and it drives you 2 and 1/2
hours up into the mountain.
And you'll get there, and you
see the glistening telescope
domes on the horizon
waiting for you.
And then it's like a tiny,
tiny little village up there.
So there are guest rooms
for the observers where
you'll sleep during the day.
So thick curtains are a must.
And when also you
get there are you'll
meet other observers from
the other telescopes.
You'll have your dinner.
And then you go
to the telescope.
And then you sit there
with lots of monitors.
And you work together
with a telescope operator.
They operate the actual
telescope and the dome
and make sure that you
don't break anything.
[ANNA FREBEL CHUCKLES]
And then the astronomer
operates the instrument.
So that's basically
a giant digital phone
camera or a spectrograph.
It's like a prism
where you split
the light into rainbow colors.
So you have your buttons to
press and decisions to make,
and, of course, the whole
strategy about what to observe
and how to spread things
out over the entire night
so that you use every single
second of telescope time
that you have because
it's expensive and never
enough telescope time.
[ANNA FREBEL LAUGHS]
And then you get tired,
but you keep going.
And you get even
more tired, and you
keep going until the sun
literally comes up again.
And at that point
in the sunrise,
you just go back to bed and
then sleep as much as you can
during the day.
And then history repeats itself.
But if the weather is bad and,
let's say, there are clouds,
or it rains, or it snows,
or something else, then
tough luck.
You go home empty-handed.
SARAH HANSEN: Now,
when Professor Frebel
is at the telescope
down in Chile,
she's getting a very
different perspective
than when she's back
here in Cambridge,
Massachusetts because the
universe you can visualize
is different depending on
where you're observing from.
ANNA FREBEL: We have
a different night
sky in the Northern and
the Southern hemisphere.
And that's because of our
orientation in the galaxy.
We live in a spiral galaxy.
And so what we see as the "Milky
Way," in quotes, on the night
sky is actually the
next door spiral arm.
And so that's why
we have a band.
Now in the Northern
hemisphere, we're
looking at the spiral
arm that's behind us.
So we're looking
outside of the galaxy.
So we're looking out.
In the Southern hemisphere,
we're looking in.
And so it's really
bright and shiny.
And that backlights
the spiral arm.
And so when you're in
the Southern hemisphere,
you see a beautiful
bright band over the sky,
much unlike what we have
in the Northern hemisphere.
It's truly remarkable
how bright this can be.
So there's time during
a single exposure
to sneak out and look at the
sky because I'm still a person.
I'm not just a scientist.
And I do like
looking at the sky.
And so I have been just walking
outside with my flashlight
under the Milky Way.
And you can actually switch off
your flashlight there and just
walk in the light of the Milky
Way, no moon, just starlight.
You can totally find
your way around.
SARAH HANSEN: I was curious to
learn more about how Professor
Frebel went from stargazing
with the rest of us
to stellar archaeology.
What made her want to dig so
much deeper into our cosmos?
ANNA FREBEL: It's just
always been with me.
Ever since I was little, I knew
I wanted to work with stars.
And I knew it wasn't planets,
and it wasn't galaxies,
it was stars.
And I can really only
describe what draws me to this
and always has is
the analogy to why
is blue your favorite color?
Why is it not red?
It's just more like a feeling.
And it really hit me when
I learned about old stars.
I did not know about old stars
specifically until I was 22.
But in Australia, I first
encountered old stars,
and I knew that that's it
for the rest of my life.
[ANNA FREBEL LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: As
I shared earlier,
Professor Frebel is the
author of the book Searching
for the Oldest
Stars, which makes
this extremely complex
topic accessible to anyone
still retaining some of that
childlike wonder and curiosity
about the world around, or
rather above, all of us.
ANNA FREBEL: These times
really speak for themselves.
People need to have more
scientific literacy.
And I think the forgotten point
is that so much wonder comes
along with it.
Information is power,
but it's also wonder.
And I think it's really,
really important as a scientist
to make your work accessible.
You don't need a
bachelor's in science
to understand that your body
is made of different things.
And we always ask the question,
where does stuff come from?
Where does the money
in my wallet come from?
That's what my
five-year-old is asking now.
So, yeah, from my bank account.
But the story is,
obviously, a lot bigger.
And science is exactly
the same thing.
I mean, I could talk to him
about the economy and the stock
market and make it really,
really complicated.
But in the end is I
have a job, and it pays,
and that's the basic idea.
And actually coming back to the
stellar archaeology concept,
I think everyone
should really know
what their ancestry is like.
And we are doing the exact
same thing in the cosmos.
We're looking at
stellar generations
and what came before.
And it's a very fundamental
question for humanity
to ask, where do we come from?
SARAH HANSEN: Part of
Professor Frebel's approach
involves pulling
back the curtain
on what astrophysicists actually
do on a day-to-day basis.
And this is something she
feels pretty passionate about.
ANNA FREBEL: The
Nobel Prize was won
for this and this discovery.
That's cool.
That's very impressive.
But is that really
the interesting bit?
I think for many people it's
actually much more interesting
to hear the journey about what
went all wrong on that path
to success.
We like to just take
the success in the end
and throw away the
99 other percent,
but that's not what life
and reality is like.
As I said, we go to the
telescope and it's cloudy.
But once I found something,
I made a big discovery,
then everyone literally
forgets how many struggles
you had getting there.
It's great to have success,
but most of life is--
it's not success.
It's hard work, and it's
facing the struggles.
And I think reminding
people that even when
you do have success
there's really much, much
more to the story.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor Frebel's
videos on MIT OpenCourseWare
are meant for anyone to
learn from regardless
of previous physics or
astronomy knowledge.
ANNA FREBEL: It's
really for anyone.
And the book is written
in the same way.
If you don't like a
chapter, you can just
go to the next chapter.
You could even read
the chapters backwards.
It's all set up
so it's completely
interchangeable and flexible.
I think that children age
10 or 15 could probably
start watching this
because, again, it's
about the big questions.
If you don't understand a
sentence or the detail, man,
don't worry about it.
You want to wonder and
be amazed by something,
it's perfectly fine not
to understand the details
because it's not the details
that make you amazed.
It's catching a
glimpse of something
bigger where you develop the
desire to understand more.
And once you want to understand
more, why, details a drop
in the ocean.
SARAH HANSEN: In
parting I wanted
to go from looking to the
past to looking to the future.
What exciting things
are scientists
doing to pave the way
for more discovery
and to inspire joy and wonder
for generations to come?
ANNA FREBEL: What I foresee
in the next 5 to 10 years
is that this combination
of knowing more
about how the elements are all
created and on what timescales,
finding, of course, additional
old stars and at all ages,
using their motions on the
sky, and then combining
that with large simulations for
the formation of the Milky Way.
And so I think there's
going to be a lot of work
into really figuring out all the
puzzle pieces that put together
make up the Milky Way.
And we've figured
out a few big ones.
But there are still
lots of little details
that we need to figure out.
And I think that that's
going to be the big thing.
So the Milky Way
in the bigger view,
in a more holistic
view, that's going to be
the focus in the next 10 years.
SARAH HANSEN:
Ultimately with the help
of educators like
Professor Frebel,
astrophysics can
be a way to become
more interested in
the world, an avenue
for understanding our
place in a much, much
larger scheme of things.
If you are ready to learn
more about the cosmic origin
of the elements or
have students who
would be inspired by
stellar archaeology,
you can find Professor
Frebel's videos
on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
Our resources are always
free and remixable.
So they're perfect for
use in your own teaching.
For nearly 20 years,
OpenCourseWare
has worked to share some of
the best resources from MIT
with teachers and
learners just like you.
From newer resources
like this podcast
to our ever-growing library
of online course content,
a gift to OCW helps us
do so freely and openly.
If you're able, please
consider supporting OCW
with a donation at ocw.mit.edu.
Thank you for listening.
I'm Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare signing off
from under the night skies
over Cambridge, Massachusetts
LITTLE GIRL: (IN BOSTON
ACCENT) Ma, pahk the cah.